you thank you for coming I love your
outfit
well I love your outfit but thank you do
want the earrings back oh okay oh
do I really laugh like that yeah
why don't you shut up
[Applause]
Joe Rogan
thank you
[Music]
for those of you listening to the
podcast
he looks like the actual Joe Rogan if he
had stage six cancer and how did you get
your head to be like that that's
impressive you went to a real
professional for the
I'm a millionaire
foreign
is that true Jamie look that up real
quick
[Applause]
is that supposed to be funny
I I'm Spider-Man okay I got one hold on
check this one out whoa I'm whoa
I'm Spider-Man
what you're going to wear for Ellen and
I said you know I'm gonna wear shoes is
it cocktail
well I'm wearing like trousers
I will wear something tight and like a
Dolce maybe but it will have fruit on it
or flowers so you know it's for the day
it's a great impression listen to this
come November 5th a lot of people are
going to be surprised by Bob Dole
because Bob Dole's going to win this
election
the thing like me first of all
I don't run around saying Bob Dole does
this and Bob Dole does that
that's not something Bob Dole does
you came on the set and you're like this
Dynamo
everybody
Diane all right
aren't you smiling
I am
that's my copy give us your best Brian
Cranston impression Brian is just very
he's very calm um
it's different uh in times there's times
and of course with a
unique it's very very his vocabulary is
amazing you know there's a touching time
it's just very Eddie's and then
occasionally he'll give you like a nice
punch line in there but everything is
poised it's all professional and and
good and you're making me sound boring
no you're not boring good morning that's
good I don't actually want to sound like
Batman
please
okay are you kidding me that this house
done my man he's so great am I right am
I right Jim Parsons
so many great answers so great my man
but Steve
[Music]
I can be John Malkovich I'm sorry
hello
my name is John Malkovich
I don't sound anything like that no no
you sound exactly like this
no I don't yes yes you do
so we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellas I mean you do what you do
I do what I gotta do if I'm there
I'm not gonna put you away I don't like
it but if it's between you and some poor
bastard whose wife you're gonna turn
into a widow brother you are going down
[Music]
what you got there I'll tell you what I
want some yeah there you go
all right you know I got great out there
yeah go on hey why don't you go out and
do the rooster I have a lot of sleep
knock it
Evans and Hemsworth were I heard Chris
saying but how do you get this here
a fair question fair question
and uh and Chris Hemsworth saying I
don't know mate like just work out and
stuff yeah I can't believe you made a
career out of standing incredible shape
and now you're endorsing my inexpensive
convenient homework if you're done
flapping your gums maybe you might want
to give Stone Cold Steve Austin the
rattlesnake a demonstration of your
stupid Tony Little push-up machine
here it is
Rob Lowe and the Spice Girls again do
you enjoy that you enjoy the Spice Girls
Paul nice girl space girls yeah yeah
yeah well they'll be on the show
and uh Paul do you you watch the
Saturday Night Live show oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what time's that on
now Paul
I say what what time would that be on
it's like uh it's 11 that's live yeah
[Applause]
if I take a paper and I start reading it
here when skip starts talking because
you know most of the time when skips
start talking all I think I hear is
Bulls you know what I'm saying because
skips doesn't know what he's talking
about most of the time and I'm just like
I know exactly what's going down LeBron
has got to get it done
there is no life wait a minute wait a
disrespect how to work that is
disrespectful disrespectful blasphemy
and I'm kicked off
it's like going into your closet except
there's a guy in there hey buddy pocket
T really thanks Gap what you refolded
this place is great
stay tuned for more of the Sammy Davis
Jr tribute honoring the one heavyweight
I would never dare happen to the ring
with Sammy you're a true undefeated
champ
oh wait
yeah
[Music]
I think Mike can do a little better than
that Mike
thank you
I'm gonna I'm gonna attempt to read this
this may be disastrous okay stay tuned
for more of the Sammy Davis Jr tribute
honoring the one heavyweight I will
never dare step into the ring with Sammy
you are truly the undefeated champion
[Applause]
the producers of the show The produces
the show was hoping you'd have a little
more feeling the more Mike you know a
little bit more Mike Tyson you know more
Mike tysonism like like hello ladies and
gentlemen Sammy and I would like I'm
lucky uh a vast God and I'm burden with
glorious purpose
um uh it's not this simple as it's not
your natural state uh you know like
um you know it's the unspoken truth of
humanity you cry subjugation
um you know uh the the bright leader of
Freedom diminishes your life's Joy
um basically what I'm saying and cut
that's awesome I can't I can't believe
you made it
wow when's the last time I saw you
Stanley it's my brother John's wedding
15 years ago I recall we stole the ice
sculpture I wonder what happened to it I
don't know it probably melted
Vanessa what are you doing what oh what
I thought because I do this great fit as
Rachel is it a great bit though I mean I
mean you know it kind of just sounds
like all you're doing is like what oh
what me oh
no no
I what
what I'm Kevin Hart right right in high
school okay um yeah hey hey
hey
can you hear me she didn't hear me
hey what's up money
no he ain't seen come on
come on
hey Miss Johnson yeah I'm gonna do good
on that test yeah
yes
my name is Dwayne The Rock Johnson
uh
known as The Champ
here doing
some interviews and I'll be interviewing
Kevin Hart
hey what's up man okay cool let's see
rock all right well we got here what we
got here okay we got all this on the
shot we got shot right here okay
about that hey make sure you give me a
thing all right
well while physically we are exactly the
same there are some slight differences
personality wise yes for example this
Nick is calm and stealthy like a ninja
warrior whereas this Nick is an
exaggerated screaming psychopath
just doesn't exist
between we hear so much about your
workout plan and I'm curious if you
could just walk me through a little bit
about what it takes to be Dwayne Johnson
oh I'm glad you asked that question
first of all you're uh Kathleen from
screen junkies right I never forget a
face I never forget a thing mine's like
a steel trap
I'll wake up at uh 5 a.m and do 27 000
rip curls uh bleed blood sweat tears
that's the approach that I take to life
that's how I approach everything life is
a delicious drink that you have to suck
deep
time like the present to enjoy your
loved ones your family of things that
the other thing and then projects I
gotta go yeah wow oh that's good so
three and a half years I couldn't fight
my best years my prime years man my
great years three and a half years the
26th 27 28 29 and a half years old
you're my best years but then out of
nowhere the state of Georgia 1970 give
me a title license to come back and find
Jerry Quarry
ugly Jerry quarry
he got cut of the weigh-ins
[Music]
the van is big is awkward it comes from
Argentina 15 rounds ago 15 months let's
knock that [__] out and now Joe
Frazier's the champion I want Joe Frazer
they ain't winner and still heavyweight
champion of the world Joe razor
[Music]
I still think I won
so welcome back
so to you
you've never been on the show
you see that look that Chuck has given
me over there that I hope it doesn't
break into my voice that's going to bend
us he does not sound like me it looks
like a fool cannot tell him he's crazy
I'm just waiting number one I from the
from the Clifford that was you talking
about I let me mirror what you're doing
over there
all right that's how bad stuff happened
around here you know it's been really
fun watching all your promos but I'm not
going to be happy they say you do me
really well
that's the problem
I'm listening right now but I don't hear
what is going with it just doesn't sound
it doesn't sound right that guy's a
knucklehead
you know let me tell you so I can't hold
on a second I never get to finish
anything here I start to say something
everybody takes it away from me how come
I can't finish a sentence in this place
what's what's the problem here that's
not bad
hold on a second
give me the camera what where's my
camera take a look now if you're gonna
switch cameras let me know okay don't
make me look like an idiot over here all
right Al always seems to be looking for
something that he's lost
my my passport
my toothbrush
my lines my performance whoa where did
that go
Al for some reason always looks a little
surprised if you look at his face it's
like what just happened
the last thing I remember I was snorting
a wheelbarrow full of cocaine and
Scarface and now I
how did that happen
Al seems to have a lot of air
just gotta get it out
whoa
I blow it out but it just comes right
back in
foreign
[Music]
mean things
hurt my feelings
Shaq a big strong man outside
what's off inside
Shaq hate bullets
everyone is calling Shack dumb
but Shaq not dumb
I have a doctorate
Charles is a dumb one
Charles Potter thing Dr red is a girl
doctor
boy doctor
isn't this Brave
another day another fifty thousand
dollars
for Jack said the one thing about
Nichols is he's a comic the bastard's
always laughing it's like working with a
damn clown and a director's chair
well when I finally met Clint he just
said to me
foreign
and I show it to all my friends
well maybe we'll just
turn the camera on and let him go
[Music]
then with Clint's help we uh we honed
the final performance down to this
little piece that I'd like to perform
for you now hey man
made me do me oh well let me ask you
this question
how's your brother
uh which one do you mean George they are
the the one with the uh with the uh the
appendicitis scar up up here and now
I've been the status is on the stomach
and nobody was so tickless
so I press play and it plays go
backwards I press rewind it actually
goes back in time take a look at this
guys man take a look at what's going on
here we're actually breaking the space
time continuum man who designed the
forward backward mechanism that goes on
with this thing I actually I was staying
in Lincoln bedroom last night and I
couldn't resist getting on the phone and
I called up the Secret Service as the
president feel like gone jogging tonight
and the node
my wife and I were looking on the
laundry at midnight these guys were
fully unclothed
well it's good to have I've been
studying him since yesterday and I think
I've actually
the way to do the president is to start
out with Mr Rogers it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood
then you add a little John Wayne here we
go let's go over the ridge you put them
together you got George Herbert Walker
Bush
that's
the thing there
now
Stephen P Smith what do you think yeah
well let me just say bye start by
clarifying as far as Mark Greenberg goes
I mean no it will no animosity or
acrimonious hostility toward him as I
progressed my favor inside any
characterization of Michael Lewis gold
liquor simply is one half of the team of
the max listening Extravaganza it is
Mike and Mike now I know Mike Greenberg
and he is a friend and when I say he's a
friend I mean that I'm sitting in the
same vicinity as him is it this current
juncture but I direct this dissertative
verbal essay is supposed to be about
positive attributes qualities
characteristics of my goal of the
Quinton essential every man a man who
accorded to the Dan Le batard program
right here on ESPN radio it's like the
guy on a construction site with
plumber's crack working on a sewage pipe
and yelling I need some light down here
he's you he's me here's the thing
there's no way he's my son
yeah here's the thing mom let me explain
first of all uh this is not my dad it's
a waste my damn time it's what it is
okay this man was my dad back then he
ain't my dad now
done I'm a nice guy
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
s the president Rickles was saying in my
dream
ah King facile of Saudi Arabia so glad
you could come
in place for your camera anyway then may
I say something Johannes can I say this
from the bottom of my heart
your face was a building it'd be
condemned
remember next time no stats on the call
huh
Pastor what are you doing here tonight
what you do get a note from the Russian
saying you could take the light off
incidentally is that a bear to you
sticking your head under your armpit
a lot of actors started doing bad
commercials remember Robert de niros
[Applause]
now that says spicy meat the ball
and of course my favorite Jack Nicholson
I can't believe I ate the whole thing
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I know
I know you love me tonight but will you
respect me in the morning
[Laughter]
hey how how about this how about this
weather we're we're having out here in
California isn't it Wild
foreign